lisa además anima juliette binoche la
más internacional de las actrices
francesas en la piel de una periodista
de radio francia internacional y las
instalaciones de nuestra radio hermana
ref y convertidas en un estudio de cine
la última película de la directora
francesa claire denis transcurre en
parte en esta emisora de la que se
volvió fan en su niñez cuando vivió en
áfrica debido al trabajo de su padre y
era para mí ref y tiene un sentido me da
la sensación de que es algo más que una
radio
[Música]
y yo escuché porque me permite no solo
enfocarme en lo que pasa en mi entorno y
me ayuda y amplía mi mirada a la
pandemia obligó a la inquieta cineasta a
poner en pausa dos películas
estadounidenses en las que estaba
trabajando un remake de the stars and
una con robert pattinson y margaret con
ley y un proyecto de documental con la
estrella de la música the weekend a
cambio decidió enfocarse en este rodaje
que realizó un poco más de un mes una
película llamada de manera provisoria
fuego fluid vinos comparte cartel con
manzana blandón
es una pareja que se ama
rajoy pero la mujer de esta pareja
vuelve a ver a un antiguo amante y eso
la hace vacilar en su vida sonríe no sé
si es la tercera vez que vino ya actúa
bajo la dirección de que a dyn ya
trabajaron juntas en un bello sol
interior y más recientemente en high
life
y también la tercera vez para landon
quien actuó en viernes por la noche y
los canallas pero nunca habían trabajado
juntos la pandemia les ha permitido
finalmente encontrarse